[Music]
super-easy and loads of fun to do
biscuits and gravy man you gotta love it
[Music]
mmm if I'm not gonna drag a lot of
utensils into the woods this is one of
my absolutely favorite meals if you
don't want to go through the hassle of
making your own biscuits just bring a
loaf of bread or some dinner rolls with
you make the gravy from the packet and
just dip it in that still pretty darn
good if you liked this video don't
forget to check out the outdoor boys
youtube channel where we have hundreds
of videos just like this and don't
forget to click Subscribe so you can see
other great videos every Saturday
morning and hit that Bell button so
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
[Music]